- Tellement hâte d'arriver
à Limoges.
Je saute dans un train
pour l'Espagne
et fini, ta sale gueule.
- Je veux pas d'emmerdes.
Pas question que vous
dormiez chez moi, trous du cul.
- Je cherche une gamine. Votre
gosse l'a peut-être croisée.
- Elle a quitté Hexagone
pour nous rejoindre.
- Et boum! Je le pousse
dans le ravin.
- Quel menteur celui-là!
- Qu'est-ce que je fous
à poil, moi?
- Le traître. J'ai entendu les
Allemands parler du Faucon.
- Le seul traître que je vois
ici, c'est toi, Albert.
- Je vais t'écraser
ta face de bolchevique.
- Ne tirez pas!
- Joue pas au héros, gamine,
tu vas mal finir.
- J'espère que ma gueule
vous revient, on va sûrement
passer la nuit ensemble.